اذا متابعه لما يحدث من تداعيات لهذا
الزلزال
التغطيه للجزائر للمستمره والتغطيه مستمره
لهذا الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وتاثرت
به مناطق في شمال غرب سوريا كما اشرنا
زلزال كان بقوه
7.8 درجات واسفر عن نحو 250 قتيلا معظمهم
في سوريا في حصيله اوليه في البلدين فضلا
عن اضرار جسيمه الزلزال وقع الساعه
الرابعه فجرا على عمق نحو 18 كم وفق
المعهد الامريكي للمسح الجيولوجي تعد هذه
الهزه الاكبر في تركيا منذ زلزال عام 1999
الذي تسبب في مقتل 17 الف شخص الهزل
الارضيه شعر بها السكان كذلك في لبنان
وقبرص واليونان وشمال العراق وكانت اداره
الكوارث بتركيا قالت ان 76 شخصا لقوا
حتفهم واصيب اربعه واربعون اخرون كما دمرت
مباني في الكثير من المدن في جنوب شرق
تركيا بما في ذلك
خوف من وجود مزيد من الضحايا اما في سوريا
فقد ذكرت السلطات الرسميه ان عدد ارتفع
الى 171 قتيلا في المناطق الواقعه تحت
سيطره النظام جراء انهيار عدد من المباني
اذا وجراء هذا الزلزال والحصيله التي تبع
في اكثر من منطقه الرقم يتجاوز
250 قتيلا ما بين سوريا وتركيا
وهذه لقطات دائما نتابعها على شاشه
العربيه للجهود لانقاذ المستمره في اكثر
من منطقه كما نتابع في هذه اللقطات لقطات
مختلفه جهود الانقاذ مستمره واثار الدمار
ايضا في اكثر من منطقه تركيا كما نتابع
وايضا اللقطات الاوليه التي تصلنا من
الشمال السوري وزير الداخليه تركي سليمان
صويلو قال انه تم تعبئه جميع فرق الانقاذ
لمواجهه الكارثه
قوه زلزال بدرجه 7.4 مدمره بشكل خطير
ونقوم بارسال قوات الدرك والشرطه والقوات
المسلحه التركيه وفرق الطوارئ والكوارث
والهلال الاحمر التركي وفرق البحث
والانقاذ من جميع انحاء البلاد الى
المنطقه
ونتابع ايضا من شمال هاتاي صحفي مصطفى
النعيمي مصطفى النعيمي ما اخر التطورات
لديك كنا نتابع معك في نشرات سابقه عدد من
اللقطات خاصه بعد انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
في المناطق
المتضرره ماذا عن
اخر المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان ونحن
نتابع ايضا هذه اللقطات لاثار الدمار من
اكثر من منطقه في تركيا
محمد والاستاذه المشاهدين الكرام نعم لا
شك ان حجم الدمار ربما قد يكون كبيرا
عندما اخذنا بان الاعتبار ان هنالك حالات
ارتداديه لهذا الزلزال يعني قبل قليل وانا
قبل ان اتحدث اليكم بقليل سيارات الاسعاف
ما زالت تحرق في المنطقه
باتجاهات مجهوله لا يمكننا التعرف عليها
نظرا لان البعد هذا المكان لكن عمليا نحن
نتحدث عن استمرار لهذه الحالات وعمليا قبل
قليل واثناء اجراء مقابله مع قناتكم قناه
الحدث قبل قليل ايضا حصلت هزه ارضيه
متواجد معكم في داخل المقابله وبالتالي
نتحدث عن استمرار لتلك الهزات والسلطات
التركيه تحذر من استمرار تلك الهداف وتنصح
المواطنين بعدم الجلوس في المباني والخروج
الى الساحات الفارغه يعني وسينجم عن ذلك
ايضا اضرار كبيره في حال البقاء او النفوس
في تلك المنازل وهنالك مخاطره كبيره من
يبقى في هذه المنازل خاصه المنازل العاليه
تحدث عن الدمار ربما قد يكون كبير فيما لو
حصل هنالك الهداف ربما الهزه الاولى كانت
حصلت كانت
بسبعه درجات فاصله ثمانيه اذا كانت خطيره
جدا مما ادى الى تلك الابنيه وبالتالي لو
حصلت هنالك هزات مستمره او متتاليه بارقام
يعني بما يتجاوز الاربع درجات على مقياس
ربما قد يكون هناك اضرار في مباني اصلا
المباني المحصنه او الاكثر يعني تحصيلا
مقارنه بالابنيه القديمه وهذا سينجم عنه
اضرار كبيره واضرار كبيره في الارباح وهنا
اتحدث ايضا عن مدينه انطاكيا قبل قليل
ارسلته للقناه قناتكم قبل قليل فيديو يظهر
حجم الماساه وهنالك الكثير يعني كثير من
الاصوات تتعلم من داخل الابنيه وهم
يحاولون انقاذ يعني يطلبون الانقاذ ولا
يوجد لديهم من ينقذهم يعني بمعنى اخر ان
هنالك حاله ماساويه كبيره تحصل في عموم
تركيا وكذلك ايضا شمال غرب سوريا تحتاج
الى مؤسسات دوليه مجموعه من المنظمات
الدوليه ان تقوم مباشره على اخلاء يعني ان
يكون هنالك حاله الانسانيه خاصه لهذه
المنطقه ليست فقط من الداخل التركي وانما
من مجموعه من الدول المعنيه في قضايا يعني
الوقوف على الزلازل والكوارث التي تجري في
الداخل التركي وكذلك ايضا داخل السوري
وخطوره هذه الكوارث ومدى واهميه وجود هذه
اللقطات الحصريه لشاشه العربيه من من
اورفا
الاثار الزلزال والدمار بشكل كبير موجود
في اكثر من منطقه وعمليات الانقاذ مستمره
ماذا عن المناطق الاخرى التي تصل اليها
هذه
المعلومات
اعتقد انضم الينا الان عهد عهد اذا كنت
تسمعني انقل لنا المشهد ما هذه اللقطات ما
هذه التفاصيل المتوفره لديك من المكان
الذي تتواجد فيه الان
التي سقطت في حي برشلونه
بناء مؤلف
طوا
بق كما تشاهدون الان
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اذا كما نتابع معهد هذه هي الصور لانهيار
احد المباني في هذه المنطقه انهيار مباشر
الان وحتى
بعد مباشره بعد حدوث الزلزال اذا هناك
العديد من المباني معرضه للمهيار عهد هل
لديكم من معلومات اذا كان هناك عدد من
السكان المتواجدين في المبنى ام لا وقت
انهياره
اذا تسمحني على ما يبدو هناك
[موسيقى]
اكمل السياره
مهدده بالانفجار في بجانب البناء الذي سقط
تحت البناء يوجد عدد من المحاله التجاريه
قبل دقائق من الان كنت متواجد في هذا
المكان كان هناك ازدحام بشكل كبير ممن
يشاهدون البناء المهدم في
وحي احمد ارصوان ثلاث ابنيه كلها متجمعه
في بناء يعني يقدر بواحد كيلو متر مربع
وسط مركز ولايه شارلي اوروبا الان محمد
على ما يبدو ان
الصوت
[موسيقى]
قطعت صوره عهده لكن مازلنا نسمعك صوت
التواضع عدت الينا الان تحدث قليلا فقط
بالتفصيل العهد اذا تسمعني بالامكانيات
المتوفره في هذه المنطقه ما الذي حصل
بالفعل هل الانهار المبنى قبل قليل هل كان
انهار مع بدايه الزلزال يوم امس ما تفاصيل
المتوفره لديك
عفوا لما اسمح السؤال ما الذي حدث
بالتحديد هل الهار هذا المبنى قبل قليل ام
مع بدايه الزلزال
من قبل الشرطه
وعلى ما يبدو ان هناك ايضا ابنيه اخرى
هايله للسقوط
في المنطقه طيب من الذي فهمته منك عهد قبل
قليل بان هذه المباني قد سقطت قبل قليل
بعد تصدعها جراء الهزه الارضيه التي ضربت
تركيا فجر اليوم اذا كنت لازلت تسمعني هل
من الممكن اخذ المزيد من اللقطات المباشره
من الموقع الذي انهارتي تلك المباني عهد
[موسيقى]
تسمعني محمد طيب اسمعك عهد ساتوقف هنا حتى
تعود الثوره بشكل كامل انه تابع هذه لقطات
مختلفه من مناطق مختلفه من الاراضي تركيا
جهود الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره لانتشال
الضحايا من تحت الانقاض كما نتابع في هذه
اللقطات على يمين الشاشه وعلى يسار الشاشه
من مناطق مختلفه من تركيا تحديدا الجهود
مستمره اذا الحصيله وصلت الى 250 قتيلا ما
بين الاراضي التركيه والاراضي السوريه
كانت الحصيله الاوليه التي وصلت من سوريا
هي الاعلى حتى الان حينما او بينما توقف
الرقم عند 76 حسب الاحصائيات الرسميه
التركيه لعدد القتلى اذا جهود الانقاذ ما
زالت مستمره لمحاوله انتشال الضحايا وكما
تلاحظون بان الاشخاص الذين يحاولون انتشال
الضحايا يعتمدون على الاصوات الوارده من
هذا المكان لا توجد ارقام عن عدد الاشخاص
المحاصرين في تلك المباني ولكن الارقام
الاوليه تتحدث عن انهيار عشرات المباني
جراء زلزال الذي بلغت قوته ثمانيه درجات
او سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه في تركيا يوم
او فجر هذا اليوم والذي وصلت تداعياته الى
شمال الغربي لسوريا وادى ايضا الى انهيار
عدد من المباني هناك اترككم مع هذه
اللقطات اذا لمحاولات انقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه جراء هذا الزلزال
نعود الى عهد مره اخرى عهد اذا كنت لا زلت
تسمعني اشرح لنا المنطقه من اورفا تفاصيل
التي حدثت محاولات الانقاذ وكنت تتحدث قبل
عن انهيار المزيد من المبانة
يعني افيدك باخر الانباء هذه الابنيه التي
تقع خلفي تماما الان وصلت اليها قوات
الشرطه تطالب الاهالي بالخروج من هذه
الابنيه لانها ايضا مهدده بالسقوط دون احد
الابنيه الذي يقع يعني على ما يقارب 200
متر سقط قبل قليل
وهناك ضحايا وعدد كبير جدا من الضحايا
لكون ان الاهالي كانوا متواجدين في
هذه المبنيه التي س
الان الشرطه ايضا
هي تمن على سلامتنا فقط نراجع عدد من
المعلومات معك عهد تتحدث الان عن انه تم
اجلاع عدد من المباني المعرضه للانهيار
جراء الزلزال قبل قليل كان مبنى نهار ربما
بعد فتره وجيزه من حدوث هذا الزلزال هل تم
تسجيل اي قتله احصائيات جديده ارقام جديده
لمحاولات انقاذ الاشخاص المحاصرين في تلك
المباني
كنت متواجد في المنطقه قبل دقائق في بدايه
اتصال متواجد تح
ديدا الله سبحان الله يعني
مستظل من الامطار الان الكهرباء ايضا
منقطعه عن جل احياء ولايه شال اورفا كما
ذكرت
لك هناك
حسب
بعضها انه لل
المنطقه قبل سقوط هذا البناء
[موسيقى]
اخر تطورات واخر الاحصائيات والارقام من
رامي عبد الرحمن مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان اهلا بكرامي بالجديد
[موسيقى]
فيها انهيارات هناك انهيارات شوارع
باكملها مباني على رؤوس ساكنيها بان هناك
ما لا يقل عن 58 بلده وقريه ومدينه بشكل
قطعي يوجد فيها انهيار للمباني الجديد بان
عدد الضحايا يتصاعد بشكل مستمر نتيجه
انقاص او اخراج حقيقه الامر بعض الوفيات
من تحت الانقاذ ولكن دعني اقول لك بان
هناك الكثير من المباني المتهمه على رؤوس
ساكنيها او قاتليها لا يوجد فرق انقاص كي
تقوم باخراج هؤلاء يعني الذين لا يزالون
على قيد الحياه من تحت انقاض هذه المباني
او حتى الوفيات تحت هذه المباني اي انها
عدد الخسائر البشريه قد يصل الى 200 شخص
ان لم نقل اكثر بكثير نتيجه وجود يعني عدد
الوفيات والمصابين بشكل قطعي هو المئات
الا لنقل يعني قد يرتفع الى اكثر
نريد تاكيد هذه الارقام السلطات التركيه
السلطات التركيه هنا تحدثت عن 76 قتيل في
المناطق التركيه وهي مناطق ربما مؤهله
اكثر
لحضاريا فيما يتعلق بعدم وجود حروب بوجود
قوات او السلطات تركيا قادره على انقاذ
المزيد من المحاصرين تحت الانقاذ لماذا
يرتفع الرقم في تركيا الى 200 قتيل وهل
نستطيع القول بان هذه الارقام الاوليه
ولكن مؤكده
وما بين مناطق ادلب ومناطق السيطره
التركيه نتحدث عن ماذا يقول عن 150 خطيره
وفيه على الاقل حتى اللحظه المؤكده العدد
اكبر من ذلك بكثير لا يوجد امكانيه لاحصاء
كافه النقاط الطبيه والمشافي في الوقت
الراهن وانا يعني اقول لك بان هناك الكثير
لا يزالون تحت الانقاض لان لماذا نتحدث عن
الاعداد في سوريا لان في سوريا مثلما
ذكرنا في يعني تعليق سابق بان هناك الكثير
من المباني الغير القابله للسكن يوجد فيها
من يقطن بها يوجد المشاريع السكنيه او بعض
المباني التي انشات بطريقه غير نظاميه
انهارت على رؤوس ساكنيها في هذه المناطق
لذلك اقول بان يعني تركيا لم تتعرض لالاف
البرابين المتفجره طيب هذه نقطه مهمه لانه
وردتنا اخبار عاجله تتحدث عن ان مسؤول في
وزاره الصحه السوريه يتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى حسب الحصيله الاوليه الرسميه الى
قتيلا واعداد المصابين الى 600
جريحه رامي اين تتركز تلك الاصابات
والمناطق الاكثر
اذا تقصد بين المناطق الاخرى التي لا تخضع
لسيطره النظام قد تكون فيها العدد اكبر
اذا تحدثنا عن ان
شخصا فقط في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
قوات النظام ماذا عن المناطق الاخرى وهل
يعني بان الرقم سيكون اكبر بكثير
بشكل قطعي بشكل قطعي عندما نشاهد شاهدنا
في احياء او مباني في شوارع كامله في عده
مناطق تهدمت بشكل كامل سواء في سرمدا سواء
في حارم سواء في جنديرس تهدم في مارع يعني
احصينا 58 بلده وقريه ومدينه تهدبت فيها
مباني هناك مناطق اخرى تضررت لم نصل اليها
الى الان يعني كل دقائق كل معلومات بان
القريه الفلانيه في منطقه ادلب قريه في
ريف حلب قريه في ريف عفرين تهدمت فيها
المباني اي ان هناك العدد يرتفع بشكل كبير
جدا هذا باعتراف لوزاره الصحه التابعه
للنظام اكثر من 200 شخص من الوفيات هناك
مئات المصابين وهناك مباني ايضا لم يصل
اليها النظام عندما نتحدث عن المشارقه
واحياء في حلب الشرقيه في الاساس كان هناك
قصد يعني كثيف عليها قبل العام 2016 ما
بالك الان هذه المباني يوجد فيها من عاد
اليها نتيجه تردي الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
النظام حتى النظام
المعابر لا تعرف حدود الانسانيه يجب ان
تكون المساعده الطبيه يجب ان تكون للجميع
لا تستطيع ان تقول لي بانك تسيطر على
المنطقه وعندما يتعلق الامر بانقاص
الضحايا تغلق البوابات الحدوديه لذلك اقول
على السلطات التركيه اولا قبل النظام
السوري النظام السوري لا يوجد لديه
امكانيات ماديه وعلى الفرق الطبيه التابعه
للايرانيين والتابعه للروس ان تقوم
بمساعده بمساعده ايضا في حلب في حلب
النظام السوري ما هي الكوادر الطبيه
القادره على انقاص هؤلاء المصابين في يعني
في مدينه حلب يجب على النظام ايضا
الاستعانه طبيه بالمناطق اخرى الموضوع هو
بامتياز وليس فقط عمليه هزات ارتداليه
الزلزال تاثرت فيه مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
ايضا في تداعيات ولكن كما تشاهدون في
اعوجل العربيه هزات ارتداديه جديده في
محافظه اتاي جنوب تركيا نعود الى مصطفى
النعيمي مصطفى ذكرت بان اكثر من مره تعرضت
وصلتك ارتداديه بعد زلزال تركيا والان
تتواجد خارج المبنى ما الذي حدث
تحياتي لك استاذ محمد مجددا مشاهدي الكرام
نعم لا شك انك قليل حصلت هنالك هزه وانا
اثناء المقابله مما قررت فاضطرني الى
المغادره في المنزل مباشره وكذلك ايضا
حصول شقوق في داخل المبنى الذي اخطن به
فيه حاليا هنالك عده شقوق في اعمده التي
تحمل البناء كذلك ايضا مخاطر التي من
الممكن ان تحصل نتيجه لهذا لهذه التشققات
لذلك لجات الى الخروج خارج يعني خارج
المنزل بعيد عن المنزل الى منطقه فارغه
ربما المبدا الخلفي تشاهده عباره عن مبنى
طابقين فقط لا غير خشيه ان يكون هنالك
انهيارات نظرا لان هذه هنالك تحضيرات ايضا
ربما قد تكون هنالك ايضا
ارتداديه اخرى وبالتالي نتحدث عن استمرار
تلك الهزات لساعات ربما قد تكون متقدمه
ولا يمكن التكهل بما هي تلك الهزات وحجم
تلك الهزات وحجم المباني التي تتضررت
نتيجه لتلك الهزات السابقه وانها ربما قد
لا تقوى على على
تكون حصينه لتلك الارتدادات التي ستخدم
بعد قليل لذلك يعني يعني ربما من شاهدتكم
انصح كل من هو متواجد داخل المباني
السكنيه ان يلجا الى الساحات الفارغه
بعيدا الابنيه والمباني السكنيه ذات
الطوابق العاليه نتيجه نظرا لان ربما قد
تنهرت تلك الابنيه وبالتالي ربما قد يكون
هنا يفارق الحياه نتيجه لتلك الهزات
الارتداديه التي من المحتمل ان تكون هنالك
هزات اخرى قبل قليل اتابع من عبر شاشتكم
انه لا توجد احصائيات رسميه حتى هذه
اللحظه لعدد تلك الهزات وبالتالي نتحدث عن
استمرار من تلك الهزهات نظرا لعدم وجود
احصائيه رسميه واستمرار تلك الهزات يعني
اثناء المقابله نحن نشاهد ونسمع وخاصه في
الطوابق العليا انا كنت قبل قليل في
الطابق الخامس لاحظت ذلك بشكل واضح حجم
الهزه ايضا الخزانات التي تفعلوا المبنى
ايضا تساقط بعض هذه الخزانات قبل قليل
لذلك اعتقد بانه يعني من الواجب هؤلاء
المتواجدين او في مناطق التي تشهد هذه
الزلا ان يخرج الى الشوارع يبتعدوا عن تلك
المنازل بحيث لا يعني ينقذوا ارواحهم نظرا
لقتل
هذا الحجم الهائل من الدمار الذي لحق بعدد
من المباني حسب الصور الموجوده واللقطات
الموجوده في اكثر من منطقه سواء صور التي
تردنا بشكل مباشر من تركيا او حتى صور
القليله التي تردنا من الاراضي يا سوريا
نتحدث مره اخرى عن هاتاي مصطفى نعيمي هناك
ارقام جديده لديكم خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالاشخاص المحاصرين تحت المباني المنهاره
هناك تقارير تتحدث عن تشققات في الطرق
وتشققات المباني كما اشرت قبل قليل مصطفى
حتى اللحظه لا يوجد هناك اخصائيه رسميه
لكن ما يمكن ان نوصله لكم وللساده
المشاهدين بان السيارات الاسعاف ما زالت
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه التي اتحدث فيها
بمعنى اخر ان هنالك ربما قد يكون حالات
جديده وكذلك ايضا ربما بعض الحالات التي
لم يتم الابلاغ عنها قد وصل ذويهم من خارج
المدينه وقاموا بايصال تلك الصوره وبناء
عليه تامه تواصل معهم بشكل مباشر من اجل
ايصال طرق الانقاذ وكذلك ايضا فرق الدفاع
المدني وصولا الى الجهات ايضا الجهات
الامنيه المعنيه التي تراقب كل ما يحصل من
تداعيات لهذه هذه الهزات التي حصلت قبل
قليل مصطفى شكرا جزيلا لك نتمنى لك
السلامه دائما في متابعه اثار هذه الهزه
الارضيه وهذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
ونعود مره اخرى الى عهد صليب عهد تتواجد
في اورفا وتتابع لنا مباشره اخر اللقطات
الوارده من هناك ورصدت انهيار مباشر لعدد
من المباني اخر التطورات لديك
نعم نعم محمد الابنيه في حي برشلونه
جميعها مهدده بالسقوط الان هنا خلفي طفله
اطفال يتحضرون للخروج من الحي بشكل تام
المطالبات في مغادره الحي الان هذه
الابنيه تعد يعني من الابيات الابنيه
الحديثه هي متشققه بشكل يعني كبير جدا
على ما يبدو يجب ان نغادر هذا المكان
حالا بسبب يعني ربما تكون هذه الابنيه
التي تحيط به كلها مهدده بالسقوط باي لحظه
كما حدث قبل قليل في البناء الذي كنت
تتواجد فيه قبل دقائق فقط يعني ربما كان
من من اقدار الله ان يكون التواصل من
قبلكم حتى اترك المكان واعود للبناء الذي
سقط ويعني انجوا من هذه المسائل فقط اسئله
سريعه نتحدث عن منطقه متضرره بشكل كبير
باخلاص سكان من المناطق بشكل مباشر
عدد المباني المنهاره حسب المعلومات
الاوليه حتى الان وهل لديك اي ارقام او
احصائيات
بشكل تام جلها يعني ما بين خمس طوابق وست
طوابق الان قبل قليل سقط هذا البناء
ويعني افاد وكل الجهات الموجوده في
المنطقه قالت ان جميع الابنيه في هذا هذه
المنطقه وهذا الحي هي مهدده بالسقوط لهذا
طلبوا منا مغادره الحي بشكل اتهام الان
يعني ربما الكاميرا تظهر بعض الاشخاص
الذين يتحضرون مغادره هذا المكان بشكل دعم
الكهرباء منقطعه من لحظه حدوث الزلزال
الان هاتفي لم يتبقى به سوى بعض يعني
عدد قليل من الشحن
في هذه الحاله عهد لا يوجد لدينا خيار
نعطيك فرصه لجميع المزيد من المعلومات
وشحن هاتفك قبل العوده مره اخرى
لتسجيل كل ما يجري في اورفا جراء الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا شكرا لك عهد حتى الان اذا
اعزائي المشاهدين نترككم مع هذه اللقطات
التي تريدونها تباعا بشان عدد من محاولات
الانقاذ في المناطق التركيه والمناطق
السوريه وايضا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل بان
هناك شح في الصور التي تريدنا من سوريا
ولكن هذه اللقطات وردت قبل قليل من عزاز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه اللقطات التي تريدنا من سوريا
ومحاولات الانقاذ وانتشار المزيد من
الناجين من تحت الانقاذ في سوريا هذه
المره وليس من تركيا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
بان اللقطات الوارده من سوريا الى حد كبير
للاسف احيانا قد يكون اتجاه الضحايا او
متوفين جراء الانقاذ ولكن هناك امل دائما
كما شاهدنا في اللقطات الاولى لانتشال
طفله
على قيد الحياه من احد المباني المدمره في
اعزاز الشغل
نعود الى مشاهد انقاذ الطفل التي تابعها
قبل قليل من
[تصفيق]
هذه التغطيه مستمره لتداعيات الزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا في ساعه مبكره من صباح اليوم
جهود الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره الارقام وصلت
الى اكثر من 250
قتيلا ربما الرقم يصل الى 300 بعد
الاحصائيات الاخيره التي صدرت عن السلطات
السوريه فيما توقفت القائم عند 76 قتيلا
وفق مصادر رسميه تركيا رقم مرشح بشكل كبير
للارتفاع نذكر فقط انه في عام 1999 عندما
ضرب زلزال مماثل تركيا وصل عدد الضحايا
القتلى تحديدا الى سبعه عشر الف قتيل هذا
العام او هذا العام في عام 1999 احصائيه
الاوليه الرقم يقترب من 300 قتيل ما بين
الاراضي التركيه والاراضيه السوريه حسب
الارقام
والاحصائيات الاوليه مازال العشرات بكل
تاكيد محاصرين تحت عشرات المباني التي
سقطت او المباني التي سقطت جرى هذا
الزلزال بعض الاحياء كما نشاهد في هذه
اللقطات مع ساعات الفجر الاولى اشبه
باحياء مدمره وكانها تعرضت بضربه جويه
نشاهد هذه اللقطات حي مدمر بالكامل ومباني
اخرى معرضه للانهيار في اي لحظه كما نتابع
في هذه اللقطات بالتاكيد هناك العشرات من
الاشخاص محاصرين تحت هذه المباني على ان
تصل اليهم بمحاوله انقاذهم فرق الدفاع
المدني نتحدث هنا عن دعوه طوارئ او اعلان
مستوى طوارئ من الدرجه الرابعه في تركيا
وهذا يسمح بمساعدات دوليه فما بالك في
مناطق اخرى متضرره مثلا في سوريا المنقسمه
ما بين سلطات النظام والفصائل السوريه
الاخرى وفي ظل سنوات من الحرب يبدو بان
سوريا بحاجه الى جهود دوليه لمحاوله انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه في هذا البلد المدمر اصلا
بسبب الحرب
اذا جهود الانقاذ مستمره وعلى اكثر من
مستوى معظم اللقطات تاتي من الاراضي
التركيه كنا نتابع لكم هذه اللقطات في
ساعات الفجر الاولى ومنذ الليل وهنا كان
الصباح على بعض المناطق واظهر حجم الدمار
الهائل الذي تعيشه هذه المناطق جراء زلزال
فجر اليوم
اذا نتابع تغطيه ايضا من شمال سوريا التي
تضرر ايضا بشكل كبير جرى هذا الزلزال مع
الزميل جمعه كات جمعه ما اخر التطورات
لديك
جمعه هل تسمعني
يبدو بانه فقدنا الاتصال مع الزميل جمعه
كاش نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه هذه الصور التي
تشاهدونها على شاشه العربيه في اكثر من
منطقه جهود انتشار للضحايا
والمحاصرين تحت الانقاض
مستمره وفي اكثر من منطقه حسب الصور التي
تريدونها مباشره هناك نعود مره اخرى الى
الزميل جماعه ما اخر التطورات لديك
محمد مرحبا بكم بساده المشاهدين تداعيات
زلزال تركيا ثقيله على مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا تحديدا في المناطق الواقعه تحت
السيطره المعارضه السوريه المواليه لتركيا
اعداد يعني القتلى ارتفع الى ساتو 80 قتيل
في هذه المناطق لوحدها معظمهم في الريف
الشرقي
والغربي
تحديدا في بلدات اعزاز
وجنديرس
لا يزال عدد كبير من الناس تحت الانقاض
فيما لا تزال يعني منظمه الدفاع المدني
والاهالي يحاولون انتشال بعض الاحياء من
تحت الانقاض وايضا انتشال الجثث ونقلهم
الى المشافي القريبه وتحديدا الى مشفى
عفرين العسكري الذي وصله حتى الان اكثر من
32 جثه
مدنيين قضوا تحت في هذا الزلزال محمد في
عموم سوريا العدد اقترب عدد القتلى اقترب
من المئتين قتيل وحوالي الالف اصابه او لا
فقط فقط دعنا نجدد المعلومات قليلا جمعه
انت الرقم الذي ذكرته في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره الفصائل السوريه المواليه لتركيا
بلغ عدد القتلى 83 قتيله كانت السلطات
الصحيه السوريه تحدثت ان عدد القتلى في
المناطق تحت سيطره النظام وصل الى
237 وبالتالي ربما المجموع يقترب من 320
قتيل ما بين المناطق التي سيطر عليها
النظام والمناطق التي تسيطر عليها الفصائل
السوريه المواليه لتركيا سؤال مهم جدا
ايضا بما ان هذه المناطق تحت السيطره
القوات التركيه هل تم
ايصال اي دعم او اي مساعدات من الاراضي
التركيه لتلك المناطق المتضرره
محمد يعني حتى الان المشافي المحليه او
العيادات الصغيره في القرى والاغذيه هي
التي تتولى مهمه استقبال الناجين من
الزلزال ومعالجتهم بينما الحالات الاكثر
صعوبه والتعقيدا يتم توجيها الى مشافي في
مدينه ادلب ومشتاق العسكري في مدينه
عفرين كونه كون يعني رئيس حلب هو الاكثر
تضررا لكن حتى الان يعني لم يكن هناك نقل
للجرحى او المصابين الى الى المستشفيات
التركيه التي هي اصلا تعاني من
الاكبر خاصه في غازي عنتاب المجاوره
للحدود السوريه يتم يعني تلقي العلاجات
والاسعافات في المشافي والعيادات المحليه
داخل سوريا حتى هذه اللحظه طيب ماذا عن
المناطق الاخرى هل هناك اي معلومات خاصه
في الغرب سوري نتحدث عن مناطق
ممتلئه بالسكان بشكل كبير جراء العوده بعض
النزوح والرجوع الى مناطق اخرى مناطق ايضا
مدمره من الحرب التي استمر سنوات في سوريا
هل هناك اي معلومات عما يحدث في حماه في
حلب في اللاذقيه وفي ادلب جمعه
محمد يعني الاعداد الكبيره للوفيات في
مناطق المعارضه تتركز في ريف
حلب بينما في مناطق النظام التي اعلن عنها
يعني هيئه الصحه الطابعه للنظام ان يعني
عن حصيله قتا تتجاوز المئتين يعني الاعداد
الاكبر كانت في حلب اضافه الى اللاذقيه
حمى
وطرطوس وهذه مدن تقع تحت سيطره النظام اما
بالعوده الى شمال غرب مناطق المعارضه فهي
يعني مناطق مقتدى بالسكان لجا اليها
النازحون السوريون من من حوالي سبع سنوات
من من معظم المناطق التي كانت تحت السيطره
المعارضه ثم السيطره عليها النظام
وبالتالي نجح اليه الى هذه المنطقه
الخدمات القطاع الصحي القطاع الطبي كلها
تشهد يعني ازمات متتاليه جاءت الزلزال
يلقي ايضا يعني
ليفاقم الازمه في هذا القطاع خاصه القطاع
الطبي ويضع السكان امام معاناه كبيره لذلك
منظمات الدفاع المدني الاكثر يعني المعنيه
اكثر بمساله متابعه هذه الامور اعلى مناطق
في الشمال غرب سوريا منطقه
من كوبا وطالبت المنظمات الدوليه والدول
يعني الفاعله في الملف السوري بالاسراع
بتقديم المساعدات في الاهالي للتخفيف من
حده هذه الازمه الانسانيه الناجمه عن
الزلزال طيب اذا كما تبعنا مع الزميل جمعه
فقط نتابع بعد التطورات ونراجعه مع ساد
المشاهدين عدد من الارقام المتعلقه بما
يحدث بعد زلزال بضرب مناطق تركيا في ساعات
مبكره من صباح هذا اليوم الرقم في سوريا
ارتفع الى 320 قتيلا هناك احصائيه رسميه
كانت تحدثت عن
237 قتيلا في
المناطق التي سيطر او يسيطر النظام عدد
القتلى وصل الى
37 قتيلا وكما تحدث زميلنا قبل قليل جمعه
عكاش عن ان الرقم في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها المعارضه المواليه لتركيا بلغه
ثلاثه
مما يرفع الرقم في الاراضي السوريه حتى
الان حسب المعلومات التي توصلنا اليها من
اكثر من مصدر الى
320 قتيل هذا في سوريا اما الارقام التي
في تركيا فتوقفت عندها 76 حسب الاحصائيات
الرسميه بانتظار المزيد من التحديث من
السلطات
التركيه
اذا هذه التغطيه مستمره على شاشه العربيه
واثار دمار الهائل كما تشاهدون في هذه
اللقطات المباشره في ظل استمرار محاولات
قوات الدفاع المدني
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من ناجين جراء هذا
زلزال الذي بلغت قوته سبعه درجات فاصله
ثمانيه درجات
صباح اليوم
نعود الى تحديث اخر الارقام والاحصائيات
من اسطنبول مع زيدان زنك واهلا بك زيدان
ما اخر الارقام المتوفره لديك حتى الان
محمد كما ذكرت انت قبل قليل ان الاحصائيه
الرسميه التي اعلنتها افاد وهيئه الكوارث
الطوارئ التركيه كانت توقفت عند 76 وهي
الاحصائيه تظهر مجددا وفق افاد 76 شخصا
نقوم 440 اخرين مصابين لكن اعتقد ان هذه
الاحصائيه باتت قديمه نوعا ما خصوصا
بيانات رسميه اخرى تصدر تباعا من عده
ولايات مثلا قبل ثمان دقائق اصدرت ولايه
كلس
بيانا اكلتي
مصنع اربعه اشخاص واصابه عشره اخرين وقبل
ذلك ولايه اورفا في الساعه الماضيه اعلنت
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا الى 29 شخصا بالتالي
ان الاحصائيه التي كانت تتحدث عن 76
شخصا لقوا مصنعهم هذه الاحصائيه باتت
قديمه وهناك تحديثات جديده من المفترض ان
يتم تحديث هذه الاحصائيه اما من افاد نفس
هيئه الكوارث التركيه او من قبل المسؤولين
الاتراك الذين
العربيه الرئيس الاوكراني بلد يقول
مستعدون لمساعده الشعب التركي الصديق بعد
زلزال نشير الى ان اوكرانيا ما زالت تعاني
من الحرب الدائره مع روسيا الان هناك
الكثير ايضا من المناطق التي هي بحاجه الى
مساعده في اوكرانيا جرار استمرار هذه
المعارك ولكن الرئيس اعلن عن استعداد
بلاده لدعم تركيا في هذه
المحنه زيدان نذكر فقط الصيد المشاهدين
سريعا باخر التطورات فيما يتعلق باكثر
المناطق تضررا في تركيا جراز
الزلزال كان مركز او قبل ان انتقل الى هذا
الموضوع فيما يخص هذا الموضوع الذي كنت
تتحدث عنه العواجل طبعا نذكر بان ازر بجان
قررت ارسال فريق انقاذ مكون من حوالي 370
شخصا للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ ايضا
وزير خارجيه السويد اعلن استعداد بلاده
لتقديم المساعده الى تركيا وسوريا في
للمساعده في جهود مكافحه
جهود مكافحه او عفوا جهد انقاذ التي
تبذلها او يبذلها الطواقم الطبيه في كلا
البلدين بالعوده الى الزلزال طبعا
الزلزال وقع في بازارجيك وهي منطقه قريبه
من مركز ولايه كهرمان مرعش الزلزال بحسب
هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد بلغت
شده 7.4 وبعمق سبعه كيلو مترات في بازارجي
كان هناك ه اعنفها في غازي عنتاب بواقع
6.6 ايضا الهداف الابتداديه وصل عددها الى
حتى الان ما زال هناك تحذيرات من افاد الى
المواطنين في هذه المناطق من وجود من هزات
اخرى طبعا عدد المناطق التي او الولايات
التي ضربها الزلزال او فيسبوك تضررت نتيجه
الزلزال عشر ولايات اكثرها تضررا لا شك
مركز الزلزال كهرمان مرعش في الدرجه
الثانيه يعني بحسب
ما رصدناها بشكل مبدئي ان غازي عنتاب وهي
المحاذيه من الجهه الجنوب لكرمان مرعش في
المرتبه الثالثه ربما هي ملاطيا واورفا
المحاذيه لغازي عنتاب من جهه الشرق وملاطي
المحاذيه لولايه كهرمان مرعش هذه الولايات
كان فيها احصائيات كبيره مثلا في
شان اورفا كان عدد الاحصائيات او الحصيله
التي اعلنها وادي الف قبل قليل التحديث
الاخير تحدث عن 29
شخصا لقوا مصرعهم في مناطق كان والي ملاطي
اعلنت في الساعه الماضيه عن ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا الى 23 هذا طبعا كهرمان مرعش
وغازي عنتاب لم يعلنان حتى الان لم يعلنها
حتى الان
عن اي ضحايا او عن اي حصيله رسميه حتى
اللحظه بالتالي الحصيله الكبرى المتوقعه
هي في هاتين المنطقه الاكثر تضررا ايضا
كان هناك شيء ضحايا في ولايه عثمانيه وفي
ديار بكر وفي كل كما ذكرنا قبل قليل في
العاجل بالعموم الناس هرعت الى الشوارع
عشرات الالاف في هذه المدن جميعا
الى الشوارع هناك تحذيرات من قبل
المسؤولين الحكوميين ومن قبل المؤسسات
الحكوميه بالعوده الى المنازل التي فيها
تصدعات وتضرر ايضا الجيش التركي وضع كل
خدماته في خدمه فرق الطوارئ
والاكثر من مره بعض المباني قد سقط بالفعل
جراء تصدعات التي نجمت عن هذا الزلزال ولا
زال الرقم عند 76 قتيلا وما يتجاوز 450
جري حسب السلطات الرسميه التركيه شكرا لك
زيدان وسنتابع معك المزيد من التفاصيل
لقطات وكما نتابع الان على شاشه العربيه
هناك لقطات على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تظهر حجم الدمار الكبير والاضرار التي
طالت مناطق تركيا بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب وشرق البلاد واثار مخاوف كبيره وسط
السكان من المزيد من الانهيارات
[موسيقى]
لحجم دمار الذي نتج عن هذه الزجاعه
من منطقه تركيا وايضا هناك مناطق سوريه
اخرى تضررت جراء هذه الهزات اذا هذه
اللقطات ايضا تظهر حجم الدمار الناتج عن
هذا الزلزال وانهيار عدد من المباني في
اكثر من منطقه كما نتابع في هذه اللقطات
المباشره لا يعرف حتى الان اذا كان هناك
اشخاص محاصرون داخل هذه المباني ام انه قد
تم النجاح ونجاح اخلائهم منها قبل
انهيارها جراء الزلزال كما نتابع ايضا بعض
الحرائق قد اندلعت في بعض المباني المهاره
وفي تغطيه ايضا المستمره للتداعيات هذا
الزلزال نشير الى الخبر العاجل انفجار في
خط انابيب غاز في محافظه هاتاي التركيه
جراء
هذا
كل التحيه لكم وللمشاهدين جميعا يعني
الدمر كما ذكرتم كبير جدا في معظم
تسمعوني
يبدو باننا فقط الاتصال وهذا بالتاكيد من
تداعيات هذه الهزه الارضيه وهذا الزلزال
وما تبعه من هزات ارضيه ارتداديه نعود فقط
لتغطيه هذه اللقطات المباشره كما تشاهدون
جهود الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره لمحاوله
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه جرى هذه الهزه
الارضيه عشرات المباني ما بين الاراضي
السوريه والاراضي التركيه التي انهارت جرى
هذا الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب وسط تركيا
مساء او فجر هذا اليوم متضررت منه اكثر من
منطقه تركيه سوريه وشعر بهذا الهزه ايضا
سكان العراق لبنان وعلى المناطق الاخرى في
ارمينيا وفي قبرص وحتى في اليونان
[موسيقى]
يا ربي
لا تحتاج الى تعليق التي وردتنا فجر هذا
اليوم لهذه المناطق التي تضررت جرس
الزلزال في الاراضيه التركيه جنوب تركيا
تحديدا مباني واحياء بكاملها قد دمرت جراء
هذا الزلزال وما تبعه من انهيار مباني
طبعا حاكم اقليم ملطيه تركيا يقول بان 130
مبنى على الاقل قد انهار بسبب هذا الزلزال
نذكر بان زلزال مماثل حدث في تركيا في عام
1999 ادى الى مقتل 17 الف شخص في تركيا
وحدها الاحصائيات الان في الاراضي السوريه
تتحدث عن 320 وفي سوريا توقف الرقم عند
سته وسبعين دعونا نحدث المعلومات مره اخرى
من الشمال السوري مع جماعه كاش جمعه اذا
الارقام متضاربه ما بين مناطق سيطره
النظام والمناطق الخاطئه لسيطره
معارضه ما اخر التطورات لديك
محمد يعني تقريبا الاعداد يعني الاوليه
لضحايا اصبح شبه واضح 83 قتيل في مناطق
المعارضه تحديدا في
اذا وكما حدث مع اكثر من ضيف قبل قليل
للمناطق الذي او التي تعرضت للزوزال او
تاثرت بهذا الزلزال تاثرت ايضا شبكه
الاتصالات الخلويه جراء هذا الزلزال اكثر
من ضيف نحاول الوصول الى المعلومات على
قدر المستطاع تبعنا لقطات مباشره من هاتاي
تبعنا لقطات مباشره من اورفا وايضا هذه
اللقطات التي تريدنا تباعا حسب المتوفره
منها في اعلى صوره تشاهدون لقطه علويه
لمحاوله
انتشار عدد من الناجين جرى انهيار احد
المباني وهي الصوره ايضا بشكل مماثل ايضا
في يمين
الصوره طبعا تركيا كانت اطلقت انذارا من
المستوى الرابع من خلال تطلب مساعده دوليه
في عمليات الانقاذ هذا ما يحدث في تركيا
فهو مبالغ مثلا في مناطق شهدت صراعات
وحروب في شمال سوريا التي تبدو بانها اكثر
حاجه الى المساعدات الدوليه في هذه
المرحله اذا جهود الانقاذ ما زالت
مستمره
اذا ايضا نتابع لحظات انهيار مبنى سكني
امام الكاميرات في مدينه اضنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بدنا نحكم العالم كلها جايه ربعه او عم
تعود لقطات التي تتابعونها ايضا تظهر اثار
الدمار التي وقعت في المناطق السوريه جراء
هذه الهزه الارضيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بدنا نحكم العالم كلها
تفرجوا من عنده نخوه
ايضا هذه اللقطات المختلفه لاثار الدمار
التي شهدتها الاراضي التركيه جراء
دمار الذي حل بعد زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
فجر اليوم وتاثرت به مناطق وولايات تركيا
وكذلك مناطق في الشمال سوريا وفي الغرب
سوري للمحاولات اذا ما زالت مستمره منذ
فجر اليوم لانقاذ المزيد من الناجين جراء
هذه
او زلزال وما تبعهم من هزات ارتداديه
بالعشرات ربما تجاوزت 50 هزه ارضيه ذكر
بان هذا الزلزال بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله ثمانيه بالعشره درجه في اكثر من
منطقه شاهدنا هذه الصور المتشابهه
لمحاولات الانقاذ وسيارات الاسعاف التي
هرعت الى المكان في محاوله لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه منذ ساعات الفجر الاولى وحتى صباح
اليوم اذا كما اشرنا وزاره الصحه سوريا
تحدثت عن 37 قتيلا
و639 مصابا بسبب او جراء هذا الزلزال هذا
في المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام كما
قال مراسلنا قبل قليل في مناطق التي تسيطر
عليها الفصائل المواليه لتركيا بلغت
الحصيله ثلاثه وثمانين قتيلا فيما توقفت
سلطات السوريه عند الرقم 76 قتيلا
جراء هذا الزلزال حتى الان بانتظار المزيد
من التحديثات حول اخر الارقام الوارده من
هناك
اذا كما نتابع في الصور المختلفه من مناطق
مختلفه من تركيا واحيانا من سوريا على
شاشه العربيه هذه اللقطات التي تظهر بشكل
كبير
محاولات وجهود الانقاذ لانتشال الضحايا
وكما تابعنا قبل قليل لقطات من سوريا
ولقات ولقطات متفائله قليلا بعد انقاذ عدد
من
الاشخاص الذين كانوا محاصرين تحت المباني
شاهدنا في صوره لافته انقاذ طفل في تركيا
وطفله ايضا في سوريا ايضا هناك ما زال
لانقاذ المزيد من الاشخاص العالقين تحت
هذه المباني التي
قدرت بالعشرات التي انهارت ومعرضه
للانهيار جراء هذا زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
في ساعات الصباح الاولى من هذا
اليوم طبعا هناك دعوات ونداءات استغاثه
سواء كان من تركيا او من سوريا للمساهمه
في عمليات الانقاذ التي
تستمر حتى الساعه لانتشال المزيد من
الناجين وايضا الضحايا الجراء هذا الزلزال
المدمر
المستشفيات ايضا كان لها نصيب من اثار
الزلزال حيث نقل الناجون المصابون في
تركيا الى المستشفيات
لتلقي العلاج في ظل تحديات لاستقبال هذا
العدد الهائل من المصابين
نحن في تغطيه مباشره معكم ونتحدث هنا عن
عدم استعداد هذه المستشفيات خصوصا في
الاراضي السوريه لاستقبال هذا العدد
الكبير من
المصابين والجرحى جراء هذا الزلزال
بالتاكيد هناك لقطات مباشره سنتابع عدد من
لقطات تباعا في محاولتنا لهذه التغطيه
هناك
مثلا هذا المبنى انهار بشكل كامل في صباح
او في تحديدا في حي سرمدا بادلب بسبب هذا
الزلزال وهذه لقطات اخرى من منطقه اخرى
هذه المنطقه التركيه تحديدا نشير الى ان
هذه الصور تاتي تباعا من خلال وكالات
الانباء مراسلين المحليين وايضا وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي فقد لا يكون لا يكون
هناك تاكيد لاسماء المناطق ولكن بالتاكيد
هذا الحي الذي انهار بشكل شبه كامل ومن
ضمن الاحياء التركيه التي تضررت جراء
هذا الزلزال
بالتاكيد التغطيه هذه مستمره لساعات على
شاشه العربيه تبعنا مع شبكه مراسلينا في
تركيا وفي سوريا ايضا هذه
الاثار للدمار الهائله الذي لحق بعدد من
المباني الاحصائيات تتحدث الان عن ما يقرب
من 320 قتيل على الاراضي السوريه فيما
توقف الرقم عند 76 قتيلا في تركيا
والحصيله مستمره والارقام مستمره والتغطيه
ايضا مستمره على شاشه العربيه